alors c'est le temps de faire notre
revue de la semaine la politique avec
nos ex fait des rouges vous les présente
un rafale là jean pierre blackburn qui
est à saguenay yvon godin qui est la
battle of skate à montréal aujourd'hui
père paquet qui est aussi à montréal
l'on saura vous tous bonsoir alors vous
le savez à chaque semaine il ya sa
surprise il ya un thème tout à coup qui
se développe et qui se met à prendre
énormément de place alors cette semaine
évidemment c'était cette histoire sur le
niqab avec ce jugement de la cour
d'appel fédérale réaction des
conservateurs qui s'est faite en deux
temps il ya eu d'abord mercredi avec la
décision d'aller en appel sur la
décision de la cour d'appel et il ya eu
aujourd'hui avec cette demande de
suspendre l'application du jugement de
la cour d'appel
tant que ce soit pas entendue en cour
suprême on va écouter tout de suite les
sulfureux rappeur c'est la nature de
notre société ouverte et pluraliste et
dans une telle cérémonie
c'est un cas de gouffran est clair qu'on
doit s'assurer des seront à visage
découvert alors je vais commencer avec
vous monsieur black pearl une réaction
en deux temps des conservateurs est ce
que c'est pas justement un petit peu
pour essayer d'étirer la sauce sur un
thème qui est favorable au parti je
reconnais avec vous que le parti
conservateur est en train d'exploiter
cette question l'autre puisqu'elle s'est
vraiment de deux positions différentes
entre monsieur marqueur monsieur trudeau
qui eux sont d'accord à ce qu'on porte
le niqab
lorsque vous prêter serment pour devenir
citoyen canadien et monsieur harper qui
dit non il met son pied à terre
edit vous venez ici au canada ça doit
être parce que vous avez une pays parce
que vous voulez partager nos valeurs
parce que vous êtes bien ici vient aussi
ça indécent des exigences et le minimum
c'est au moins que lorsque vous prêter
serment
mais vous devez avoir le visage
découvert et je crois que monsieur
harper va élargir son électorat avec
cette prise de position et cette semaine
d'être venu là dessus de montrer que
c'est sérieux
en plus ce qu'il va déposer un projet de
loi alors je crois que c'est il est dans
la bonne direction je pense que les
largement les canadiens partagent là
celui qui a été mandatée par le parti
conservateur justement pour porter le
message de ces réactions en deux temps
c'est monsieur denis lebel une fois ça
s'est fait dans le secteur de trois
rivières la deuxième fois aujourd'hui ça
s'est fait dans le secteur de la région
de québec quant à québec même comme tel
pourquoi est ce que c'est parce que
c'est un thème qui est davantage porteur
qui vous permettrait éventuellement de
faire plus de gains et six au québec
mais je vous dirais lorsqu'on a vu ça
cette semaine la personne qui vous
voulez être assermenté avec le visage
vous allez ça déplaît fondamentalement
tout le monde c'est comme si on n'en
revient pas comment quelqu'un peut-il
faire ça alors qu'il veut devenir
canadiens chez nous ne pas partager
cette valeur de base
alors bien sûr on est en train de
l'exploiter je pense de la part du
ministre harper les deux du parti
conservateur et ça devrait donner un
résultat est du moins une plus value au
moment d'aller voter j'ai une question
pour récolter mais je répète ma question
d'avoir effet d'abord les réactions
parmi ceux de bell
ici dans les provinces de québec c'est
parce que les gains affaires sont
davantage ici bien c'est quelque chose
qu'on exploite bien sûr ici dans notre
province et je pense qu'un nouveau ça
rejoint tellement de gens dans leurs
valeurs alors c'est bien de l'exploiter
ici revenue aux pros luminus ils
pouvaient ministre a clairement pris
position cet après midi je vois monsieur
gaga qui est en train de réagir je sens
que vous voulez parler mais avant de
vous laisser pas brillé sur ce thème là
j'aimerais qu'on écoute aussi la
position justement des autres partis
parce que chacun a été obligé se
positionner sur l'enjeu on écoute en
rafale les autres réactions
il faut que les gens comprennent qu'on
exige que la femme qui porte le niqab
s'identifie en se dévoilant c'est
obligatoire
qu'ils essayent de rendre plus difficile
pour des communautés des individus qui
ne votent pas souvent pour le parti
libéral parti conservateur mais le voit
un visage
couvert des services par la fonction
publique offert est reçu à visage
couvert des conservateurs sont comme le
npd et les libéraux et sas servier en
pleine contradiction avec les valeurs de
la société québécoise où il ya presque
unanimité à dire non ce qu'on comprend
particulièrement avec les réactions de
monsieur du cepici du bloc québécois
c'est que le bloc de même un peu plus
loin que les conservateurs sur cette
question là pour vous monsieur paquet
c'est aussi un thème qui est porteur
finalement pour votre parti oui mais
c'est une position que le bloc depuis
très longtemps michel guimond qui est
décédé malheureusement avait déposé un
projet de loi à cet effet là lorsqu'il
était à la chambre des communes donc
c'est pas une position qu'on sorte du
chapeau et d'ailleurs comme vous le
savez la loi 65 qui est à l'étude
actuellement l'assemblée nationale
reprend exactement ce à dire que le vote
doit se faire à visage découvert la
réception et l'offre de service public
aussi et par voie de conséquence une
cérémonie d'assermentation doit aussi se
faire à visage découvert alors là dessus
on est un diapason avec la population
québécoise
un sondage a montré que 91 % des
québécois et des québécoises appuyer
cette idée que certaines giresse
certaines actions civiques doivent se
faire à visage découvert et encore une
fois monsieur duceppe le mentionner il
ya seulement un bloc québécois qui
défend cette position là et d'ailleurs
si les conservateurs avaient été plus ou
moins opportune et c'est plus honnête il
aurait déposé un projet de loi avant la
fin de la session parce qu'on sait que
le projet de loi ont été déposées
quelques jours avant le déclenchement
des élections donc est mort au
feuilleton
et ça a été le cas aussi à la dernière
législature alors si monsieur harper
avait été plus je dirais sincère il
aurait pu régler le problème et les gens
découvrent maintenant la position de
monsieur mulcair seul de justin trudeau
je pense qu'elle est tout à fait
conforme à la position des libéraux
depuis et pierre elliott trudeau alors
là dessus je peux je pense
qu'effectivement ça va faire très mal ou
npd au québec
l'ajustement au revoir monsieur gaudin
qui représente le npd ici monsieur
connaît votre chef donne l'impression
ménager la chèvre et le chou sur ce
thème là effectivement monsieur pas
quelqu'un qui parle de l'unanimité
l'assemblée nationale on l'a bien vu
cette semaine l'ensemble des politiciens
qu'ils hissent serment de citoyenneté
doit se faire à visage découvert ça sera
pas facile pour vous au québec de faire
comment dire de préciser votre position
mais sans perdre des appuis
non mais en même temps vos raisons
bluffe pas je vais inviter comme freaks
pour parler de la crise et la manière de
relever nos chine où c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas ce problème là mais moi je me
rappelle avec dans le temps que
en argumentant sort à la chambre des
communes
l'argument que moi j'utilise et comme
j'étais au comité des procédures d
affaires de la chambre avec monsieur guy
me disait monsieur yvan d'astreindre
silva en dit que la personne doit avoir
enlevé ce un handicap pour aller voter
ça veut dire que on devrait arrêter les
votes à partir de la demeure aujourd'hui
la tuque voter à partir de la maison qui
sait pas comment ce que c'est que tu
aimais mobile
c'est je veux dire qu'ils utilisent sont
faut gagner des votes
moi je trouve ces imac pour moi c'est
malsain de le faire de la manière que
fait le gouvernement
j'ai toujours j'ai toujours défendu que
le droit de la personne la charte des
droits et dans ce cas qu ici là c'est ça
que je suis interdit ça s'envoie la cour
suprême si en quoi le système de oui
mais la première voiture a pris 50 et
des déclins le système de justice qu'on
a des courses ça sans voix devant la
cour suprême ça via le pt de la charte
des droits des personnes
alors pourquoi quand nathan peau est la
cour de la décision sap a commencé dès
hier cela problèmes leurs séjours
derrière l'été du nom je sors ou à
l'élan je suis aussi de mettre sur le
dos des humains et peut-être 30 le droit
de la personne aussi je trouve que c'est
la meilleure position
c'est pas entre le chou et la c'est pas
une position qui est facile mais on est
content quand même que monsieur maingain
naviguent sur des hawks sont pas
évidentes là dedans tu que sa marge de
manoeuvre est bien bien ms quand même
secondaires
oui mais c'est ça mais c'est parce que
ce que c'est la publicité qui font
dessus on divise pour régner en davis
les gens plutôt de travailler ensemble
mais il réussit vous sent comme
l'ensemble c'est simple et le bloc
québécois est en train de faire peur 80%
des vieux sont encore ouvertes oui bon
c'est bon je suis donné ce godet merci
monsieur paquet on va laisser la baronne
madame cops qu'on n'a toujours pas
entendu vous ans que votre chef a le
mérite d'avoir été clair sur la question
on ne le sent pas en train de ménager
quoi que ce soit ceci dit à quel prix
c'est la question parce que lui défend
là tu vraiment la position de la charte
des valeurs c'est ce qui les évoquent à
chaque fois qu'il en a mais je pense
aussi comme kama de la charte de valeurs
excusez-moi de la chanter droits de la
personne donnée vous
certaines femmes ça m'agace quand je
vois les gens qui sont couverts de de
tête aux pieds
mais c'est aussi vrai que quand j'étais
jeune je me souviens je me suis fait
refuser l'entrée pacifique s'attendent
parce que je portais des chocs puis
j'avais des manches courtes
donc quand j'étais jeune toutes les
fermes étaient obligés d'avoir le
chapeau je suis pas d'accord avec le
niqab c'est pas moi qu'il parle puis je
pense que la question est ce que la
personne qui va tu es ce que le bel et
bien identifié par une autre femme avant
qu'elle vote oui c'est pas une personne
qui arrive couvert puis elle doit de
procéder
c'est une personne qui avant ceux des
voix devant une autre femme est ensuite
se portent une culture que moi je n'aime
pas une culture religieuse
sa peau était qu aux élections dans le
groupe mais oui dans les élections aussi
les gens étaient habitées et non celui
de machines à sous ont été perdus quand
je dois il se disait que ce sont des
joyaux du tout ceux des voleurs ils
s'exposent derrière une femme à
l'extérieur du tour de scrutin
et ceci dit si on veut changer étendant
moi je veux que ça change parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est aux primes le
statut de la fin mais ça doit venir de
parle à personne en particulier
si la société dit t'as pas le droit de
porter le niqab
prochainement il va dire tu n'as pas le
droit de porter le
le turban cas pas le droit d'apporter 50
ans passés comme maman porter le chapeau
plus mouchoirs oui elle l église oui
c'est pas la province qui a dit de
l'enlever
c'est pas le premier ministre du nouveau
brunswick qui a dit enlève son chapeau
c'est maman qui a décidé de me sens
chaque pouce à la table plus vous en
veut plus à l'elysée qui avait sauvé les
chats persans les valeurs de laïcité de
la société québécoise et même la société
canadienne parce que au moins 83% bellac
et canadiens qui sont en déjà contre
cela l'incité de déchets nadière mais la
laïcité des canadiens c'est pas dans la
loi c'est trop mais justement c'est que
moi je n'aime pas son choix
mais quand même c'est une choix
religieuse qui va à l'encontre de la
majorité des religions au canada mais
c'est quand même une paire il allait
mettre convaincu de la vie politique
culturelle des droits libertés de
monsieur trudeau monsieur paquet madame
comme je vais relancer la question
maintenant ici à monsieur blackburn
parce que finalement la stratégie des
conservateurs c'est de dire on va
contester en cour suprême
et on veut suspendre l'application de la
décision de la cour fédérale entre-temps
ceci dit en cour suprême c'est pas gagné
non plus c'est pas gagné non plus
justement parce que vous entendez vos
adversaires et six sont en train de
parler sa réponse quand même sur une
charte est ce que ça veut dire que cette
charte on va devoir la remettre en
question le premier jugement a été sur
la réglementation exactement c'est pour
ça que le gouvernement veut déposer une
loi très claire
quelqu'un qui veut devenir citoyen
canadien qui veut justement adopté notre
beau pays doit au moins se découvrir
pour prêter ce serment
d'autre part moi je pense que cette
fois-ci et monsieur trudeau et monsieur
walter sont dans l'erreur
ils devraient le reconnaître ils
devraient reculer là-dessus et dire
c'est vrai quand on veut devenir
canadien au moins faisons un amusant et
notifiés par exemple s'identifie d' il
s'identifie car personnellement j'ai
juste faux claviers la cérémonie mais
oui mais à ce moment là pourquoi la
cérémonie si cécile c'est la cimentation
a lieu avant la cérémonie qu'on abolisse
la cérémonie
si on décide quand passer une loi qu'est
ce que ça pourrait faire qu'est-ce que
ça fera c'est à dire que ces femmes là
sont obligés de se dévoiler
il a dit les conservateurs exploitent la
crise en changeant et la raison pour
laquelle il a fait l'annoncé à québec
puis puis dans les faits la question
soit parce que c'est pas du canadien
sensible il n'y a pas tellement des gens
allemand et jean pierre qui qui portent
le niqab
on attend bien entendu sur ce thème là
on va passer un indien uma des boys
certains disent on ne voit presque
confidentielle on va regarder un petit
extrait tout petits de ce débat alors
voilà avec vous voyez je suis dans un
très court extrait mais on va parler de
l'image que donnait ce débat qui avait
pas les côtes d'écouté sont les des boks
ont exposé dans les grandes chaînes d
ici on s'entend c'était sur la chaîne
parlementaire s'était sur youtube aussi
mais la pression que ça donne c'est
vraiment un peu la bagarre là où quelque
chose d'un peu chaotique par moments
entre le chef du npd le chef libéral
et quand on revient monsieur raquin on
devait me sur un point qui semblait leur
joie en que dans son attitude beaucoup
plus en contrôle un peu l'écart de ce
type de bagarre avez vous l'impression
monsieur blackburn que vous avez gagné
des points avec ce débat vous savez des
fois même nous mêmes dans cette émission
aussi des fois c'est cacophonique
lorsque l'un et l'autre parle en même
temps mais ceci dit d'abord si les gens
savaient comment un débat dans une
campagne électorale c'est ce qui est
plus difficile pour un candidat pour les
chefs vous devez vous préparer
vous avez le stress vous avez peur de
vous tromper la peur d'oublier en scène
et vous
et en même temps promouvoir votre
programme électoral or pour moi même si
des fois c'est cacophonique
n'empêche qu'à la fin il ya des
analystes politiques les journalistes
qui font leurs commentaires sur le débat
ils le font au tant sur le contenu que
sur la force et aider les jeunes
canadiens de même informé mais ça a été
pratiquement un débat pour les analystes
à tel point il était peu regardé
justement parce qu'il était diffusé sur
une chaîne
organisé par le bureau bains de mer mais
diffusée sur une chaîne qui doit très
regardé quand même aux choses sérieuses
et là c'est la faute des conservateurs
ils ont peu évolué prendre c'est ça
social c'est vraiment triste parce que
regarder pour un exemple et francophones
au québec les grands les francophones
dans bien des places au canada qui a un
qui ne sait pas qui n'existe pas chez
les autres
oui mais même moi je souhaite de tout
les canadiens doit avoir la chance
d'écouter les chefs doit avoir la chance
d'écouter c'est quoi qu'il en a proposé
puis moi je trouve ça terriblement
regrettable c'est inadmissible c'est
inacceptable c'est complètement puis
radio canada puis c'est bien ici est une
télévision publique qui ce que le
canadien se donne puis refusé que ça se
passait comme ça mon discours qui trouve
cet intérim est allé voir le modérateur
lui même c'est même pas un gars de la
télévision il était pas capable de
prendre le contrôle
on voit par les journalistes et si
monsieur harper il faut le dire jean
pierre c'est monsieur harper qui a
refusé le consortium des grandes gueules
du fiso qui passe le message il
préférait voir ces petits endroits
il sera néanmoins de moins de mes mails
encore misé auront l'occasion de
surprendre parce que des débats y en a
d'autres - trop tôt qu'elle est
impliquée justement un réseau canada
écoutez vous toujours très vite quand on
est en votre compagnie c'est déjà le
temps de vous y remercie la semaine
prochaine nous tous au revoir
il